there's a page that I followed out
called Karen's gone wild [ __ ] taking off
[Music]
alright so how many of you guys and
girls wear face masks I thought you're
talking about like when you go to sleep
like the beautycon yeah oh do you do
that - no I do what I do the normal face
yeah I hang my name my rearview mirror
so whenever I'm like I got to pull it
down and you let people know I hate ya
got one of these babies even when I go
through a drive-thru and I know they
have one I put it on - just cuz I want
to make them feel comfortable most
drive-through is now saying that you
can't grab your food unless you have a
mask whoa churches is like that
Yoshinoya is like that you can't even go
to go to the window without one I
haven't even been to a drive-thru in a
minute I actually haven't really been
leaving my house at all like really you
never really have to wear your milk cuz
steve is an extrovert and feels caged in
like oh yeah like if we go Sri I can
picture the man as a leopard mask put a
car all the time yeah yeah I bought
really cute at sea masks and then I
forgot that like he's like I didn't buy
any masculine ones the tiger King came
out so you actually like city like Rock
City well Steve does not belong in this
category of men because there's a new
study saying that men are less likely to
wear a face masks I believe if they see
them as a sign of weakness you know it's
really weird when you see a couple right
go to like any public space and only the
wife has a face mask and I'm like that
defeats the purpose yeah only one of you
has it might as well not have is the
same thing woman's show what a little
[ __ ] you are because you don't want to
look like a [ __ ] like everyone that's
concerned to look like weak
I think they are even funnier yeah I'm
hard I'm hardest [ __ ] I don't even need
a mask
this is weak-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] that just
highlights their insecurities saying all
right I'm like what the [ __ ] man why the
same kind of guys who like won't wear
pink or any like female colored right or
let it print right yeah yeah I never I
never once thought on putting a mask
would make me feel like more like a
[ __ ] yeah yeah well I mean you know
what does make you look like a [ __ ] is
someone who's concerned of what other
people think you know yeah it's like
dude there's guys out there that are
[ __ ] really hot girls in high-heeled
shoes with mascara on and his name was
Prince the cholos in my neighborhood
they're just wearing bandanas that just
what they were wearing before [ __ ]
wear this without any judgment issued
afterward oh just thinking it's still
way yeah yeah they're like I'm safe well
being robbers are like yes we can
finally be in our element been anything
robbers I there are people doing crimes
now because they can use this as a way
to hide yeah I've heard that yeah I went
to the bank for the first time during
this whole thing right it's actually
inside inside and I felt really [ __ ]
weird like pulling up to it with my mask
on and I'm like should I like walking
without the mask on so like the care
cameras but yeah you got me cheesin so
you know who I am and then I'm gonna put
the mask on so don't come out with some
guns and security guards right but then
but then there's like a [ __ ] line
outside the bank and it's like 6 feet
apart well show them
I'm at the beginning of this people were
scared of the face mass look so then the
the PSA they released was that when you
enter a store he's also flash or mouth
or okay so you know quick second of call
the nineteen yeah but yeah so they're
saying the fact that men are less likely
to wear masks might be attributed to the
fact that men are more likely to believe
that they are not going to be a they're
gonna be unaffected by the disease
meaning like men think that they're not
going there strong boys yeah I can punch
away the virus so which makes them less
likely to wear the mask
that's how immune systems work guys do
engage in more risky behavior and
stubborn behavior when it comes to a lot
of things that's why we die younger like
the place of where that's like being
heavily like in force or their friends
are the ones that are being like don't
[ __ ] your where though they're not
wearing it they're the ones that like
social stigma yeah let your wife tell
you what to do and the people that go
out to like those like lakes or whatever
still like take like hella beers and
[ __ ] like those are the type of people
like the college kids that don't want to
wear because they think they're like
cool water we can't drink a beer through
than that yeah sure I get it
one of my comments okay one of my cop
friends keeps going wanted me to go
shoot with them and he was come on we're
gonna go shooting how to go shooting on
my god I'm a you're a frontline worker
you see too many people that I can't be
hanging out with you because I have a
mother-in-law he goes don't tell me one
of those [ __ ] Millennials that
believe in this [ __ ] and I'm idea where
I'm asked is like yeah well I guess like
but just in case he believes in the law
so if the law comes aware mass will
always follow it right but then in terms
of the mentality behind it it's like he
thinks everyone's a [ __ ] which is funny
dude that was mean in beginning to like
me and Tim for getting to like actual
arguments about like how to conduct
ourselves as everything was unfolding
right and I was like I don't think it's
that big of a deal I'm gonna go Gator
okay okay cuz like well if it really
does happen I don't think I'm gonna be
able to get your haircut I'm gonna go
get a haircut and she's like why would
you want to do that risk everyone's
lives it's not just our lives it's
everyone else's lives
else's longer you guys seen this is your
lives
Oh anyone in passing I guess you know
which I get now I get now bad bad but
that was like all right before the
lockdown right yeah done even we didn't
have all the animation yet but like for
sure I was fighting against it for a
long time I feel like grocery stores are
still one of the worst places there has
to be oh yeah for sure
I want to see the most people everyone's
touching stuff they're still like it's
the rattle on it yeah I've been ordering
my groceries and it's been a lifesaver
the only thing so I've been using this
service called hung group not sponsored
hungry route and you can pick up a diet
you're on you so you could pick like
paleo can you can Oakley whatever diet
Your Honor I put dairy-free pescetarian
you could get really custom like that
Wow
they send you like organic food like
produce and like grains all kinds of
meat and all kinds of show you don't
they pick it out yourself
no and they give you recipes that go
with the ingredients that's like
blueprint it is but it's not just one
recipe it's like they send you a bunch
of ingredients and then you can mix and
match and you can make whatever you want
matches to your diet yeah and it matches
to your diet and the all the recipes
have been like 10 minutes and it's been
half the price of my regular groceries
during the how it is how does your final
deuce I found on the in Surrey oh man
it's so good
send the marketing team this video you
know dude I'm like sponsored me because
I've been talking nonstop about this
[ __ ] cuz it's so good the only thing
they don't send it you DM them you
should you I have it why didn't you I'm
not good at I'm not good at like asking
people to sponsor me or make an
alter-ego and call it Nikki's manager
and then do it from that you're crazy
[ __ ] don't matter
Cray sorry
firefighter I have another one her name
is Nikki yeah I know but it's been dope
the only thing they don't send is like
staples like oil no good actual staples
yeah everything but like actual staples
it sucks oil and milk or like to cook
the stuffing so you would probably have
at home already
but yeah you don't really go I like pick
individual spices no I hate when that
happens dude like I got some mac and
cheese the other day and I was like I'm
gonna make some and it's like low-fat
milk and I'm like [ __ ] I had to buy a
whole thing a low-fat milk just to make
a little bit of [ __ ] mac and cheese
man I'm like who drinks this much milk
maybe normal people a little bit of
cereal I'll even drink more like that
I'd be eating cereal every day so yeah
you could have my milk man it's just
chilling bit cuz it shut for weeks bro
you can have it I wouldn't make it much
of overnight oats with money Oh
because I hate try like think about
making food in the morning like between
me and my girlfriend I make most food
all the time but she makes breakfast
because I don't want to think when I
wake up oh yeah oh that's why you prep
everything the day before overnight oh
just put in my mouth half asleep I just
cut fruit sometimes but yeah I don't eat
until noon yeah intermittent fasting
yeah it's it's actually kind of better
unless you are that like some people
just need some calories in the morning
though I need it I feel like it makes me
slower if I Iran okay it makes me slower
but since usually when I'm not in
quarantine I'm like on some sort of diet
that I'm like here's my chance to eat
all the cereal in the world
well you to mostly if I do that night
okay yeah it tastes way better at night
interesting okay you're stuck this
enhances the flavor
I don't know cuz cereal its programming
your mind to think that's like a
breakfast thing or in the morning like
you're breaking the rules
oh just desserts or pancakes so her
french toast
I mean like American breakfast is
literally just cakes in the morning just
carbs and sugar yeah so [ __ ] good good
it's like
not a big breakfast person how dare you
yeah any breakfast well I'll get the
burger or some beer steaks they're so
dumb
I know 8 a.m. in the morning you'd get a
burger he does know yeah some weird [ __ ]
that's probably better than what you
guys eat no way Jose what you kidding me
in terms of health senator french toast
Oh french toast in the shape of a spiral
listen in French toast is anything you
don't even know anything about this
about myself before you even say
anything bad about right you ever have
eggs benedict [ __ ] not really
and you call yourself a cook so you're
not even enjoying a burger properly you
gotta play an egg you know then it's a
breakfast burger I bet you're a foodie
bro just do that only eggs yeah
absolutely
look at your steaks on Instagram they're
in the same way ever again
because I don't like eggs yes
yeah you don't eat steak and eggs that's
one of the healthier things filet mignon
and eggs it's healthier than a hamburger
for sure yeah it's how they're way
healthier than a man breakfast mood is
so good though Mexican breakfast a lack
of chilaquiles chilaquiles
Oh dim sum come see you're just saying
you like savory foods yeah I I want a
breakfast food that I eat in the morning
and puts me back to sleep that's what I
[Music]
[Music]